one of the things i i think that i've
discovered in the last year is i've
become attracted to unplugged women
because i believe there's blue pilled
women who are plugged in as well and one
of the traits that i see in in plugged
in women is that if they're
complimenting a man and being
complimentary to him and i don't want to
say a subservient but being good to
their man
society tells them that they're being
oppressed
so again back to what jaron said these
combative
um western plugged in women well i want
to say you know women who consume a lot
of pop culture think that you know
they're being abused and not abused but
they think they're
been oppressed in a relationship but
they're not um and again if you come
across a girl that isn't plugged into
any of that nonsense stuff can be a lot
more free-flowing easy going and you're
not dealing with
a confrontational you're dealing with
someone who knows that a man's been a
man
she's been a woman and that is not an
oppressive relationship it's a symbiotic
relationship what about the whole like
narrative that you hear where women are
just like i want to find my equal and
it's like
i don't i don't understand guys that
like seek that right you know like i
want to be with a career professional
woman with degrees on her wall frame to
mahogany with little lames letters after
her name
climbing a corporate ladder coming home
and then you know crapping on you
basically you know you you go out and
you do your thing all day you want to
come home and you know have a peaceful
life not um you know deal with a hashtag
boss girl or sass girl or anything like
that right it's like
one of the problems that
needs to be addressed um and you know
whether it gets addressed or not is
relevant to me i don't give a [ __ ]
because there's loads of women out there
that are still feminine um is that if
you want to have a good experience with
women and you're a conventionally
masculine guy that's chasing excellence
you know you look good you lift weights
you make bank you got game you got a
good circle of network you're you know
you're interesting you're influential
you're you're captivating guy you're not
boring and [ __ ] you don't really want to
deal with a boss girl right you want a
feminine beauty that's going to
complement your life that is um you know
going to be useful to you like if you
get sick
who like who's going to take care of you
your boys
like
i love them off i love you guys
gonna come over and take care of me if
i'm [ __ ] sick he's not right but a
good woman will do that right you know
she'll feed you she'll clean up your
place afterwards you know sort of thing
yeah
they made fun of him yeah guys don't
yeah guys won't take care of you
yeah they'll make fun of you exactly
yeah
stop being such a [ __ ] you get it done
right yeah i had a bad head call this
weekend i was on the sofa and i got like
tissues and and hot tea delivered to me
and i'm like where does come out of
yeah yeah guys will be like yeah see you
later we're going out yeah exactly yeah
most guys don't know what they're
bargaining for when they talk about that
kind of stuff they they've a it's the
fear of burning of performance and they
don't want to take responsibility for
you know if you're going to have 100
authority then you need to take 100
responsibility and they say oh well two
incomes are better than one because then
we can get a better house and we can get
a better this and better that
and it's i'm going to share 50 of the
responsibility so i don't have to be the
decision maker
because they just don't understand
hypergamy at a fundamental level and
they don't understand what sort of
character traits and attitudes generally
are going to come along with boss girls
boss vapes this whole thing and just to
go back to the earlier point really
quick
i think what this really just boils down
to
is
pay attention to
how you feel when you're around this
chick right do you enjoy being around do
you enjoy spending time with this person
because
look a lot of guys that
they've
gone through a couple of women they've
got their notch counts or whatever a
decent you know count is i don't even
care what it is at this point but there
does seem to be a certain point where it
just becomes like yeah it's fun
but pay attention to how you feel about
this person if you're not in the bedroom
you know 95 jared and i talk about this
all the time 95 of the time you spend
with a woman is not going to be unless
it's a pure friends of benefits hookup
situation is not going to be in bed in
the throes of passion so if you have
these feelings where you just can't
stand to be around them and you just
want them to get out of your house or
you just want to leave as quickly as
possible then that's telling you
something you know if you can spend time
around this person and actually have a
conversation with them and it doesn't
have to be you know
i often talk about and say how well men
and women generally are on different
planets or come from different universes
so we just because we don't experience
the world through the same lens doesn't
mean that we can't talk about things or
have conversations that are going to
benefit us both so just paying attention
to generally how you are when you're
around them are you rushing out the door
or do you not mind it cool like
we can actually talk about
the sort of content we make or we can
actually talk about what's going on with
work and job and things like that uh do
you just generally like being around
this person
or in general i say um bring her like
this is all frame theory but like bring
her into your world so like the one i've
got here right now i'm like earlier i
thought like okay like i'm free from
this time to this time i have this show
gotta get going so i was trying to like
kind of rush her out and then i came out
i was like i was like hold on i never
asked you he's like you don't want to
leave do you it's like no it's like
stay in the bathroom i don't care like
like
duh jaron like let's get it together but
you know she's but now like you know i'm
gonna need food here in a bit i'll just
mute the mic and tell her to go order me
food and i'll get it here so it so it is
really really nice but um going back to
the listening thing it was that point
like if you don't ask the question like
oh yeah like what are you looking to get
out of this because the deeds already
been done after that like you're just
two human bodies occupying space you're
like oh i should probably get to know
this person uh
and women have a lot of awesome
qualities that they can they gladly
exhibit if you know how to bring it out
of them
and it's like you got to pay attention
right to like kind of like that balance
of energy right like the the ebb and
flow right you could as guys get
sensitive right now to be like all woo
and everything but you can sense when
you're around someone if they're kind of
like positive like help kind of help
uplift you or like kind of like help
bring out the best of you and you can
kind of feel they're vibing off of that
as well um because that's where the boss
babe can kind of be a bit of a misnomer
sometimes because a lot of boss babes
right
are like that because the average guy
out there has set the bar so abysmally
low that they've literally had to adopt
this persona in order to basically like
have their kind of own bodyguard to keep
them from being bamboozled because a lot
of guys just aren't really bringing it
up to the table so even if you're
picking up like 10 of the stuff that
we're telling you right now that's gonna
put you so far ahead and you'd be very
shocked and surprised where you can meet
a lot of top you know quote-unquote boss
babes and it's like really at the end of
the day
based on a guy that's you know about his
business on his purpose but knows how to
really elicit that energy so that way
they don't have to be in full blown like
boss babe i got to take over handle
everything mode they can just kind of
sit back relax a little bit and hey you
know hang on the couch watching garbage
tv for a couple hours every weekend you
know it's it's self-preservation it's a
survival instinct that's all it is
it's not that you know it's
self-preservation and survival instinct
combined with
feminist brainwashing essentially but
that's a recipe for they you know look
like they're looking around for where
are the guys that are going to
fulfill this archetype and fulfill this
their sort of quote-unquote
responsibility
uh but and and you're right like pigeons
are slim these days you know as women
become more masculine men are becoming
more feminine by the day so you know
they feel that they have to fend for
their own
uh and also they're being told that you
know that's going to make you attractive
go make your money go sleep around go
get the career go be the ceo and then by
the time you quote unquote made it and
you have x amount of dollars in the bank
there's been guys lining around the
block to come marry you and it's sadly
not the reality uh but you know look
it's not it's not their fault they're
being sold a bill of goods that isn't
real and they're also
uh
they are operating purely on emotional
survival instinct because yeah you can't
um you can't expect that level of
ownership to be taken from you know from
women when it comes to their to their
choices hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you